Pope Francis is back at the Vatican this
morning after the Catholic World Youth
Day rally in Panama Seth Doane traveled
with the Pope as he discussed the
church's upcoming summit on sexual abuse
and his fears of a bloodbath in
Venezuela
Seth is with us from now from Rome good
morning good morning Pope Francis told
us onboard that plane that he believed
that expectations should be deflated for
that much-anticipated February summit
here at the Vatican that will be looking
into the issue of clerical sex abuse he
said that sex abuse is not just an issue
in the church but it is a problem
through all of humanity he said the
first step is to recognize the issue and
in some cases bishops don't know what to
do he spoke out strongly against
abortion and offered some personal
advice he had four mothers who had had
one he said that they should sing
lullabies to their children in heaven he
spoke out in favor of celibacy for
priests and sex education in schools and
he also made news regarding the conflict
in Venezuela while he did not take sides
he said he stood with the suffering and
was terrified of a bloodbath
John sat down in Rome thanks so much
Seth